it's the worst crisis the country has
seen in more than three decades a
violent crackdown by police and military
in Chile against thousands of
demonstrators has left several dead
thousands of others have been arrested
repression has been horrible they beat a
boy to death with clubs and the media
here lies as always the rich are sitting
on top while we always get stepped on
demonstrators blame the government for a
long list of social problems from
economic inequality to a growing lack of
access to public health care there's no
medicine there's no supplies to treat
wounds we don't have enough stuff there
is a massive deficit according to
medical professionals dozens of
protesters have suffered wounds from
firearms and have sustained injuries to
the face and torso from projectiles like
tear gas canisters and rubber pellets
the United Nations along with
international human rights groups are
calling for security forces who have
been documented using excessive violence
against peaceful protesters to be held
accountable
there have been specific cases not only
violating the right to peaceful assembly
but also the right to life and bodily
integrity there have also been cases of
sexual assault things that cannot be
tolerated on Wednesday
Chile's sub Secretary of the Interior
said he expects that any alleged human
rights violations will be thoroughly
investigated we are living under a state
of emergency and I military curfew but
this doesn't not justify human rights
abuses while a majority of protests in
the country have remained peaceful
there's also been widespread vandalism
and hundreds of businesses have been
looted a military enforced curfew has
been announced for a fifth night in a
row and has been extended to other
cities of Chile the concern now as more
people continue to join in the
demonstrations and violate that curve
for you is that the violence that we've
seen over the past few days will only
worsen
between protests that continue to
intensify and a government who seems
unable to regain the trust of the public
a peaceful solution to the unrest
appears to remain out of reach Manuel de
pollo al Jazeera Santiago Chile